un studio photo sur les toits plusieurs
mètres du sol maxime rouzaud en illinois
de 35 ans a décidé d'apprivoiser à sa
façon la jungle urbaine parisienne une
passion transmise par l'un de ses amis
il y a huit ans quand je suis arrivé sur
instagram c'est vrai que j'ai vu qu'il
faisait ça moi je faisais la photo
depuis très longtemps donc du coup on je
dis bah tiens j'aimerais bien j'aimerais
beaucoup un jour te suivrai y aller et
puis c'est un petit peu comme ça que
j'ai été croqué de la première fois que
je les fais j'ai trouvé ça vraiment
extraordinaire c'est à couper le souffle
c'est vraiment on est sur le toit de
l'une des plus belles villes du monde
mais on a l'impression d'être un petit
peu seul et d'être privilégié parce que
on a un regard sur sur la ville que
personne d'autre n'a aps
après avoir débuté par des photos de
paysages urbains maxime a décidé
d'associer monuments parisiens et modèle
photo sur ces clichés
ce jour là il était avec cette mannequin
pendant une heure c'était génial c'est
trop cool on avait vraiment eu en plus
chez soleil magnifique
donc c'était top ce qui est génial c'est
qu'ils te mais vachement confiance enfin
moi je suis arrivé j'avais un peu le
vertige et du coup un peu d'appréhension
et au final c'est très vite partie parce
qu'il met les gens à l'aise et c'est ça
qui est vachement fait un travail
atypique qui lui a également permis de
collaborer avec de nombreuses
personnalités j'ai eu des demandes assez
atypique de j'ai shooté des célébrités
et des youtuber très connus miss france
j'ai même ajouté
miss univers donc c'est une petite niche
dans laquelle je me plais et dans
laquelle je suis connu pour ça et qui me
va très bien
maxime n'oublie pas dans son travail sa
ville de coeur saint germes en ligne
commune où il est né et a grandi
le photographe immortalise régulièrement
ses monuments sur son appareil toujours
à plusieurs mètres du sol
c'est une ville qui dégage vraiment
beaucoup de choses j'aime beaucoup parce
que elle a un petit côté un petit peu
ville de caractère ville un petit peu de
province tout en étant très très proche
de la région parisienne un petit
caractère un peu village que j'apprécie
énormément
j'aime beaucoup saint-germain là il ya
vraiment une atmosphère particulière que
je n'ai pas envie de lâcher capter les
contrastes les ombres des nuages
l'ambiance d'une ville toujours
changeante à travers son objectif
un défi que maxime se lancent trois à
quatre fois par mois en moyenne avec des
sorties plus régulière au printemps et
en été avant de s'aventurer sur les
toits le photographe étudie longuement
les alentours des lieux cachés dont il
veut garder le secret pour les conserver
c'est du boulot c'est vraiment beaucoup
de boulot c'est des fois des après midi
entière de travail parce qu'on cherche
un petit peu sur google earth
les différents alignement de 2 comme je
disais tout à l'heure de monument qu'on
pourrait avoir qui pourrait être
intéressant jouer avec la tour
saint-jacques et puis la tour eiffel
jouer avec tout un tas de monuments
vraiment ça nous ça nous tient à coeur
de trouver des trucs comme ça donc du
coup assez facilement une après midi de
travail de recherche des recherches pour
dénicher les meilleurs spots maxime veut
continuer cette passion pendant de
nombreuses années avec toujours cette
idée de partager ses clichés avec le
plus grand nombre sur les réseaux de
notre côté nous n'avons pas résisté à
l'envi d'immortaliser ce moment unique